in other cities cops are actually
committing sexual assaults on duty so I
thank God that this is what passes for
controversy in Austin Texas at some
point she knows it's about cops and
Austin stop cuffs on the daughter after
she ran across the street
Jett headphones on and apparently
couldn't hear the officers telling her
to stop an eyewitness says the officer
grabbed her from behind which may have
startled her good ultimately cops
through a manager Steven behind bars for
failure to identify the cop after a
lawful question that she is wofully
required to answer and she didn't that's
why she went to jail and she got off
easy according to chief art acevedo who
says he would have added resisting
arrest to her rap sheet you're the man
chief that's why you're chief chief well
she got off easier than Ken long who had
a bloody encounter with the NYPD after
he crossed the street against a red
life-long doesn't speak much English
the officers apparently didn't speak
Cantonese so they used the universal
language of force when the confused 84
year old tried to walk away from them
what you just did remember do walking
crackdowns have absolutely nothing to do
with raising revenue they're all about
keeping pedestrians safe that's why cops
are dishing out $200 tickets in LA and
busting 328 illegal Walker's in a single
day in San Diego for offenses that
include entering the street after that
don't walk light blinks a tad too long
in cops in New York are also sticking
joggers with summons that could cost up
to a thousand bucks what was Peters
Jackman's crime running in Central Park
before 6:00 a.m. so why you out before
6:00 a.m. anyway suspicious
unfortunately I did it at 4:30 in the
morning and maybe tops to skate exercise
the Husky fellows in Austin look like
they might but what's the big deal right
chief in other cities cops are actually
committing sexual assaults on duty so I
think
god that this is what passes for a
controversy in Austin Texas pop I'm sure
also nights are grateful for not being
sexually assaulted by your officers but
come on chief bill cops had better
things to do welcome according to a
recent survey locals would shocker
rather have cops spend more time solving
violent crimes than driving tickets for
how about busing car thieves car thefts
are on the rise especially in the area
where cops arrested the jaywalking
jogger ok maybe Jim walking crackdowns
do increase safety not for pedestrians
but for the cops who are shaking down
peaceful people instead of tangling with
lowlifes who might actually have guns
and knives solid show on Twitter submit
your nominees for next month then check
out JC Otero this month's featured
follower is a big shot with Twitter in
me are you twittering me no jaywalking
on my watch